while out for an a lat blasted crossbow
princess retain his heart was pierced by
Cupid's arrow but the hope of new love
does little to erase a past of evil exes
some shadows you never escaped sweetches
India hardly recognized a new horns or I
just got the Varner cool cool cool um so
what you've been up to
oh my gosh I've been busy as a monk I've
got a new dragon Christa princess to
death by Spinz oh you know I'd see her
eggs there oh yeah usual cool he's still
datin what's her face she was seen mom
may attend to the stables behind my back
so I burnt down her castle and
slaughtered all our horse you know I
heard about that and instantly I was
like that was for India I thought that
was you cool I've seen an ogre I need to
score into a lifetime of being formed by
bees don't think heavens I thought you
had left me impossible
blooming spell it was that your old
flame yep I always envisioned her to be
more ugly was that yeah
why did you two cut ties who where to
begin
she was incredibly jealous kill her like
right now like right now feel good she
was incredibly self-obsessed Hey you
ready to go I am the fairest of them all
okay I always had this sneaking
suspicion that when she was mad at me
she was trying to poison me thanks but
I'm actually allergic to apples damn it
to him
why did you court for so long I don't
know
maybe I just didn't think I deserve
better
oh hell do you remember that Horseman
who wooed me at the hopkins cher - yes
he's here
got the plague he look great Oh
apologies for the delay it turns out
there is more than one way to get a
channel so is strictly metaphorical
wasn't shall we share a pint and listen
to all my problems while I have no
interest in hearing any of yours
actually trendy up I'm busy that's
adorable but see I have volts power over
you so are you showered named you know
it's fine conjure up a spell to paralyze
me kill my pet goat Francis Francis was
11 poisoned me again who told you that
was poison I'm no longer captive deer
darkness we'll see about that
we'll see Latanya you pecks her nowheres
told her the truth but do you think you
can do better look at this look at all
of this
how'd it go at the bone someone killed
all of the horses in the castle so he's
quite mournful Oh to culture and waters
for me and my best handmaiden please oh
thanks princess be wood the tree love so
a different political system that offers
upward mobility honey wine please thank
you
pages and so with the spell of her
former flame broken the princess and her
royal contractor funny and right you
really understand what and drank the
satire